Joey Bosa situation the Ohio State
defensive lineman taken number three
overall by the chargers they have pulled
their latest offer off the table and the
Chargers went public on this and then we
reached out to boces people and they
said well we don't want to comment and
publicly and then they released a
statement so I just wanted to get a
neutral party here because if I talked
to boces side they of course are gonna
say the Chargers are the bad guys if I
talk to the Chargers then both sides the
bad guys so we bring in andrew brandt
from the Monday Morning Quarterback also
works for ESPN their NFL business
analyst kind enough to join us Andrew
summarize this situation with both sides
good morning then you know this is
interesting because the CBA is people
know predetermine what these guys make
so there is no dispute the moment he was
drafted we knew what joey bosa would
make in terms of numbers over four years
in terms of his bonus how much he'd make
every year that's set so what are they
arguing about well this offset language
that if down the road it gets cut signed
with a new team they relieve the
Chargers of that guarantee down the road
all teams except for a couple seemed to
be doing that and getting it done with
the agents and then of course the
payment terms on the bonus 17 million
the charges originally put about 8
million of that into 2017 the agents
went nuts they said well all these other
pics are getting it all in 2016 and that
was the standoff for about five six
weeks until recently we hear from the
Chargers they move that they move from
like fifty percent of that bonus in next
year to only fifteen percent of it
paying eighty-five percent of it in 2016
the agents say that's not good enough we
want it all in 2016 because that's what
third pics get and now they've retreated
to their corners calling names it's
everything else I think you have to give
some credit to the chargers for moving
they moved whatever million dollars from
2017
into this year but as you mentioned in
the open den this public shaming you
know I've been on both sides an agent
I've been with the Packers ten years
that to me is unique to actually come
out on Twitter publicly and shame the
player in age and then talk about taking
the money off the table publicly that's
unprecedented to me well bosa has very
little power here players have very
little power in these situations I mean
he's not going to sit out this year and
then go back into the draft and if I'm a
team that would draft him I'd have
second thoughts because of a situation
like this he's reducing he's going to
lose all of this money it's a year later
to get into that bigger contract so I
mean he's going to eventually have to
come in with his tail between his legs I
would imagine right yeah as I said I
mean people he's not sitting out I mean
he's not going to take a stand for a
whole year over over a few a couple
million dollars of deferred money so
that's not happening the Chargers know
he has no leverage the rookie pay scale
has obviously gone down players have no
options they can't even renegotiate a
rookie deal until three years in the
league so yes he's going to come in but
I predict this and I predict yes oh come
in before the season of course he will
and I predict if he wants that offer the
charges are allegedly taking off the
table yeah they'll give it to him I mean
of course they will I just don't
understand they've okay I want you to be
his agent now yeah what would you have
or what would you advise him to do right
now I thought we were going to ask what
our position would be which is it hey
all these third pics they get it paid in
2016 and the charges they will we don't
do it and the agents say well third pics
to it and you have this continued
standoff I think if I'm advising bozo
I'm saying there's no way as I said
you're going to walk away from this kind
of money is there any way we can move
more of it so a Carson Wentz has 1
million dollars in the next year is
there any way that can get to that only
1 million of that
18 million dollar bonus can they get to
that it's so short-sighted though Andrew
get in prove yourself you know that this
league humbles a lot of people it
humbles everybody eventually get in get
to know your teammates contribute and
you're gonna you're going to survive
without a couple of million dollars for
this year I mean it's just it doesn't
make any sense here I know the Chargers
they they were they were a little slow
on the trigger to get up to where they
should have been in the first place but
still you know what you got to get in
camp you just know I think the thing
here is that the Chargers are imposing
their will and that's what turns a lot
of people off but teams do this
certainly the Patriots I mean teams
around the league do this all the time
with players with no leverage of course
they do but it's not popping up that's
what you hurt them yeah that's what
hurry and then you get these ideas well
you know that the stadium issues coming
up and why are they doing this but yes
they know it will happen they know he
will come in and we'll hear from him and
the agents and the team we're all about
football in a couple weeks well this
will be long gone but right now the
agents are trying to do this and they're
saying we may not see the Chargers do
anything until they absolutely
positively have to they think they have
obviously moving this money up but maybe
just maybe this were the agents are
thinking just maybe at the start of the
season they make another move and if
they don't they don't but i don't think
if boza says I want that deal that you
just allegedly took off the table I
don't think they'll make them put rub
their nose in it good to talk to you
Andrew thank you for joining us we
appreciate it I was a pleasure damn all
right that's andrew brandt from the
Monday Morning Quarterback also ESP on
their NFL business analyst these guys
get in late they're so far behind as a
rookie are you in shape are you in
football shape and inevitably these guys
get hurt they just do you have to you
know they know who they're negotiating
with against now this this isn't the old
regime with the chargers to be fair to
them but do I think they were too slow
to get to where they needed to be yes
but Joey Bosa has got to understand get
the money prove yourself and if you
prove yourself you're going to be
laughing at one or two million dollars
if you're that good get in you're going
to get your money and then you're going
to get really paid the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience